hey everyone I am Kristen Gill and this
is how to Hollywood and I have Spencer
Barnes here with me celebrity makeup
artist and beauty expert at great beauty
calm everyone and we are about to do
Julianne Hough sweating makeup so if you
guys want to learn how to create this
look and get all of the details from the
wedding maybe some tea some extra
exclusives he's giving us then please
keep watching I start with clean dry
hands and then smooth and Pat this serum
all over the face and then bring it down
onto the neck this is like liquid gold
I'm obsessed with this product what it
contains is bio placenta which it gives
the skin like this amazing new skin feel
now I'm mixing two products the co Gendo
and I mixed in with it
the co Gendo aqua foundation illuminator
you can use it alone or mix it in with
foundation like I've done here and what
it does is it gives an additional
luminosity if you've thought about
someone on their wedding day they just
have our radiance love is a powerful
thing and it brings an amazing glow to
the skin so we want to work with natural
ingredients and products to help bring
that out lose this love glow even more
we can have the love glow you did
Julian's makeup on her wedding day
what was her vibe how was she feeling
how are you feeling getting her ready
for that day jewels as you know I have
worked with for about a decade now so
for me to see her through to this most
special of days for her was
unforgettable what is your favorite
Dancing with the Stars looks like you've
ever done on her Wow there's been so
many been so beautiful every season has
like 12 or more episodes with the finale
shows and whatnot so I would that's
tough wow there's so many this year had
a little bit more of a polished edge and
I really like that
this is a powder a setting powder what
I'm doing is locking your foundation
into place I wanted to keep it fairly
light but even out the complexion now
I'm going to use a product on your lid
this is called
eye silk by beauty by pure a it's a
primer and this one's a neutral matte
when did you meet Brooks I remember when
she first got back after meeting Brooks
and the way they met here's a fun story
Brooks had seen a video a commercial
actually it was the very first thing
that I worked with Julianne on it was a
juicy fruit commercial Brooks saw that
and told his friends I don't know who
that girl is but I'm gonna marry her one
day dad I know right years later he was
like I really want to meet meet the
right girl how am I ready to settle down
and one of his friends said I think I
have someone that would be perfect for
you I didn't say no no introduce them
they talked virtually for about two
months and when they finally met they
had an incredible connection and I
remember I was getting her she and Nina
Dobrev ready who are at best gal pals
for a Michael Kors event and Brooks
called
oh my gosh I'm telling you her face lit
up like I've never seen and I watched
the way he talked to her they were
facetiming she kind of left the room
mm-hmm when she came back she sat down
and I was like
you bet your god happened this is the
one and she she got teary-eyed and she's
like I know I don't know how about I do
oh my gosh they say when you know you
know yeah just to give you I'm using
some neutral matte colors this is like a
peachy nude toffee color this tan color
I'm building out your eye with natural
shades but creating an elevated
structure mattes will give us the
ability to create that shading and
definition a very natural way and mattes
will photograph a little bit differently
than shimmers anyway but with something
as important as a wedding day I find
using mattes on the lid is a great place
to start and then you can add Sheen and
luster where you want it if you choose
to so you'll notice that we've built out
a neutral palette on the lid we've got
some matte shadows here and then going
into some Mavi tones in this part of the
eye I'm going to add just a little bit
of sheen on the inner corner I'm going
to use this concealer crayon right under
the brow and then blend with my fingers
this is going to give you an exaggerated
brow bone and because it's a creamy
pencil it blends really easily and
it looks natural so if you see a little
bit of a peach tone right on the lid on
the center of the eye just a little bit
to create a little more dimension then
I'm going to use a slightly taupey color
right in the crease so if you don't know
where that is on you just look look up
and you'll see where the crease
naturally folds and then look down and
we're going to gently blend into the
crease area and this is a slightly
grayish brown shadow and the reason I
chose that is because it actually looks
like a shadow especially in photos it
will look very natural just a tiny bit
more bronze tone in the outer corner now
I'm gonna use waterproof mascara yeah
why do you think that's handy for
weddings because everybody's gotta be
tears of joy
so let's definitely start by working
this mascara I'm not done with the eye
but I'm going to do a little bit of work
on the face I am going to warm your skin
with a little bit of this is a benefit
product called hula light jewels for
instance had her hair back in a bun and
what it left was an exposed neckline
that was a little bit less 10 than the
rest of her face so I brought around the
hairline back here behind her ears and
it really helped even out everything a
lot of people are wondering how we came
up with this look you know with this
busy as Jules was she was of course
touring with her den store clear up
right until before the wedding we didn't
get the luxury of a trial but
fortunately I've worked with her so much
I know her face like better than anyone
we wanted to dial it back and make it
absolutely timeless so we talked about
how to achieve this in a way that would
look great in photos and read but also
keep her looking very fresh and so we
opted for a cleaner look one of the
things that made our date challenging is
we have a lot of paparazzi that were
there so we decided to do the wedding
makeup at 5 a.m. and shooter pictures
from 7:00 till 9:00
and they really have yep Wow and it
would turned out to be the most peaceful
easygoing morning to get her ready and
that's amazing she was very happy with
that I'm gonna use a little bit of this
Luminizer stick I'm gonna place a little
bit on top of the cheeks by the I go
find getting a little bit of sheen and
luster in all the right places will help
elevate the luminosity and the dimension
of your makeup I'm going to use a tiny
bit of contour to add a little more
subtle dimension and then you use a
little under the cheek area here I'm
just gonna do a little on the sides of
the nose with photos sometimes a flash
will flatten the face so by adding a
little bit of subtle contouring you
ensure that the structure still reads
and you keep that 3d quality even though
your your now flattened into a 2d photo
sometimes I'll even come in with a
little contour by the eye area we are
going to do the slightest bit of copper
under the eye have you look up and
here's another secret you can do brown
mascara on the bottom for a more natural
look and then I also saw on the site you
put pictures of the different
celebrities and what products you've
used on them
I saw Megan Markel on there if you work
with her often - I've worked with her
many times of the years she's incredible
of course there's a lot of talk about
her her new beau I know that's why I'm
asking I'm like if there's a royal
wedding she calling you Spencer yeah so
we've got brown on the bottom lashes and
here's another trick to keep the eye
bright-eyed and open I'm going to use
the flesh toned waterproof eyeliner that
is designed to go on that inner
waterline it just looks fresher brighter
and more open eyed now I'm gonna put on
some short lashes and let's just jump
right into the lip I'm gonna use lip
crayon it's kind of a Mavi pink and this
is a little bit softer than the lip
color and it has a little more gray in
it so that we get a little bit more of
the illusion of a fuller lip line
because it looks like a shadow around
the edge of the lip I'm going to use a
concealer under your eyes and just to
give a little more dimension in certain
places your browser in such great shape
I didn't have to do a lot but I'm gonna
do just a subtle bit of filling in
[Music]
okay so this is the final look that
Spencer has created on me that he did
for Julian's wedding thank you so much
for being here with how to Hollywood
make sure you guys subscribe to our
Channel and let us know in the comments
below if you have any questions